la ville de lviv frappé à son tour par
les missiles russes mardi en début de
soirée plusieurs explosions ont été
entendues depuis le centre ville une
heure après que les sirènes des raids
aériens ont retenti
sur place les pompiers sont à pied
d'oeuvre les tirs ont touché plusieurs
centrales électriques plongeante une
partie de la ville dans le noir
les conséquences de la frappe de
missiles sur le vivent se poursuivent
actuellement les frappes ont ciblé trois
centrales par conséquent il ya des
coupures d'approvisionnement en
électricité
deux personnes ont été blessées elles
reçoivent une aide médicale
les frappes ont aussi visé des stations
de pompage provoquant des coupures d'eau
relativement épargné au début du conflit
vive la grande ville de l'ouest de
l'ukraine est devenue une ville refuge
pour des milliers d'ukrainiens mais elle
subit des bombardements plus fréquents
depuis quelques semaines mardi soir des
frappes ont aussi été signalés dans
plusieurs régions d'ukraine notamment en
transcarpathie une région frontalière de
la hongrie touchés pour la première fois
depuis le début de l'invasion russe